cae la noche y la lluvia de misiles
continúa en el cielo de gaza La tregua
entre Israel y Palestina en la que
Egipto estaría trabajando entre
bastidores está lejos de concretarse la
última noche más bombardeos israelíes
volvieron a golpear el enclave palestino
varias personas murieron entre ellas el
cuarto comandante militar de la yihad
islámica la política de bombardeos de
viviendas civiles en la franja de gaza
no afectará a la resistencia Palestina y
no debilitará el frente interno de la
resistencia Palestina los bombardeos de
Israel han sido una respuesta a los más
de 400 cohetes lanzados por militantes
palestinos contra territorio israelí
desde el martes el Primer Ministro
benjamine tanyao ha dicho que los
combates aún no han terminado
ciudadanos de Israel seguimos en medio
de la operación
en este mismo momento nuestras fuerzas
están atacando ferozmente la franja de
gaza
se están cobrando un elevado número de
víctimas entre las organizaciones
terroristas quiero reiterar quien nos
haga daño quien envíe terroristas pagará
el precio
esta nueva escalada se produce tras la
operación israelí denominada escudo y
flecha ataques aéreos que mataron el
martes a tres altos cargos de la yihad
islámica y le costaron la vida a varios
civiles palestinos entre ellos cuatro
niños la ONU está muy preocupada por la
situación y quiere asegurarse de que no
empeore la violencia